au soir les enfants offrent aux nounours
j'ai bien l'impression que ce soir
nicolas et pimprenelle attendent avec
impatience vous croyez pas trou técher
petit je descends les voir tout de suite
michèle o o allons l est pas très belle
celle là je la bats les manches lé pour
papa gâteau nicolas il me voit que je
les découpe et après celle là est la
légende tendu elle est pour papa nicolas
il veut pas bien si des coupes et des
voitures ses preuves au jeu plonge on
tue beaucoup te dis non tiens on peut
pas regarder de la note tranquille
maintenant c'est quoi des boeufs deux cd
dame n'a pas idée des nénettes tiens
regarde non celle là l'est pas mal la
gare oui moi je peux pas d'écouter des
folklores pop en crumble
ce journal est intéressant c'est pas
marrant vous line ou voilà ce qu'il nous
faut nous les petits déjeuners pour ne
pas grossir à l'air bon y'a des
croissants moi aussi j'aime les
croissants je viens d'écouter bâton un
peu petit de je ne sus chocolat ou un
[Musique]
jus de fruits divers céréales d'hiver ce
moment je garde paf
ourak sp mou au fond bacon fromage
confiture d'airelles alors c'est bien
non
bon ça doit être dur avec petits pains
au lait c'est un petit jeune et pour ne
pas grossir
ça m'a donné ça ce petit déjeuner moi
aussi tu es né voilà du miel et moi je
découpe tranquillement ma petite voiture
rongeait ça fait du bien à la grange ma
gorge de la patron
j'accuse
allô oui oui non y'a pas preneur
oh
démon
[Musique]
bonne nuit nounours d'euros via deux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
les gourmands sont toujours punis alors
ça va nous nours pile trop ça
t'apprendra à faire le vide un goinfre
bonne nuit les enfants embrasser bien
fort vos parents faites votre toilette
ne l'oublié pas et en dormez vous bien
sagement à demain bono nul
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]